[Musica]
allora la storia che vi sto per
raccontare comincia grazie a tre
ingredienti il dalai
ipol in home ed i grado maggiore o
uguale al terzo e la canzone squalo che
alla siae la società italiana per autori
ed editori è registrata come squalo
autoreti fini cosimo mandiamo verone
allora il primo ingrediente il dalai chi
è il dalai il il dalai era il quarto
nome dell'appello in quella seconda cdu
liceo scientifico nella provincia di
firenze in cui insegnava nel 2015
matematica l'appello citava più o meno
barsanti casini colesanti dallai ora io
mi ricordo come se fosse ieri quando a
fine lezione il dallai con una
naturalezza disarmante
si alzò spezzando quel brusio classico
da fine elezioni dicendo o prof e
comunque oggi ci si è capito nulla è
grande e profondo via visitava intanto
torna subito a sedere è poi non capisco
perché non ci si è capito nulla come che
parla numeri tutti i tuoi compagni forse
non ci ha capito nulla e ci chiedono
anche fatto un casino tutta l'ora quindi
la prossima volta ascolti e vedrai che
capirai molto di più presi delle cose e
andai via indossando sai proprio la
maschera del professore quello sicuro di
sé che alla situazione in pugno quello
proprio grande quando in realtà ai madre
mi sa che dolor perché le parole del
dalai mi avevano colpito mi avevano
ferito hanno pizzicato quel nervo
scoperto lo hanno fatto venire tutta la
mia ansia da professore fuori la mia
ansia di professore alle prime armi bene
questo è il primo
ingrediente vediamo nel secondo i
polinomi dichiarato maggiore o uguale al
terzo o meglio una regolina che serve a
scomporre quei voli no e che va sotto il
nome di regola di ruffini o regola del
teorema di ruffini una regola tanto
potente nella matematica moderna che è
studiata trasversalmente in tutte le
scuole superiori e che voi a rovigo
conoscerete perfettamente chi di voi non
scompone polinomi la mattina come se non
ci fosse un domani proprio ora che cosa
dice dice una cosa molto ganzak e se tu
c'hai un polinomio che noi chiameremo pi
grande dx di grado maggiore o uguale al
terzo si può cercare di scomporre questo
polinomio nel prodotto di due polino e
come andando a cercare un numerino
trazionale q piccolo tale che se
mettiamo col piccolo al posto della xe
facciamo tutti i calcoli il risultato
poi venga 0 ora se si riesce a trovare
questo numerino cubicolo razionale che
cosa si fa superiamo qua di avere una
bella lavagna così faccio finta di
scrivere e voi vedete dalla parte giusta
si fa a quel procedimento meccanico che
tutti voi almeno una volta nella vita
avete visto si fa una tabella
così si mette q piccolo qui in basso a
sinistra
i coefficienti di pi grande dx qua in
alto e poi via con le danze s'abbassa il
primo coefficiente si moltiplica per cui
il prodotto sotto al secondo
coefficiente somma algebrica quello che
viene siri moltiplica per chi si mette
sotto al secondo coefficiente somma
algebrica è così che è così che quello
che viene in fondo in basso a destra
nella vostra tabella è zero
o meglio è zero se avete scelto bene il
numerino un piccolo e se avete fatto
bene tutti i calcoli nella tabella ma la
cosa veramente sensazionale che quello
che trovate in basso nella tabella sono
i coefficienti di un polinomio q grande
dx tale che rullo e samb
grande dx la più grande degli spurs
aperta fonda hicks meno un piccolo
chiusa tonda che è una roba
straordinaria abbiamo incontrato in
maniera semplicissima scomposto il
polinomio più grande ed ora quanti in
questo straordinario teatro vorrebbero
fare come il dall'aia alzare la mano e
di rebellion c6 capito nulla è
tantino le mani alzate sono parecchi me
ma perché normale la matematica è
difficile non ci si può girare intorno
questo era il secondo ultimo ingrediente
è
la canzone squalo che alla siae è
registrata come scuola l'autore fini
cosimo l'alta domanda è chi di voi
conosce fini cosimo che quando era
piccino
veniva preso in giro da tutti gli
amichetti perché all'occhio sinistro
leggermente più chiuso dell'occhio
destro viene chiamato guercio ora
succede poi una cosa interessante che il
piccolo fini cosimo cresce anzi cresce
parecchio e si prende una bella
rivincita contro i bulli perché quella
presa in giro
diventa proprio il suo primo nome d'arte
infatti il suo primo nome d'arte è il
guercio che poi diventa gue pequeno ora
come direbbe l'avvocato federico buffa
il resto della storia lo conoscete tutti
cosa successe squalo di cui peqin io
tornavo da quella scuola in provincia di
firenze con la mia ayari cena comprata
nel 2013 verso casa a firenze quando dal
mio spotify rigorosamente in modalità
non premium tra una pubblicità e l'altra
parti
squalo di qe pequeno una musica lontana
da quello che avrei voluto sentire
lontana dai miei gusti tanto che è
ancora un po infastidito per quello che
era successo pensai ecco questa deve
essere la musica che ascolta quella fra
va del dall'aie sicuro sicuro
l'illuminazione
fermi tutti cominciai a rivedere quella
lezione che avevo appena fatto da un
punto di vista
completamente diverso cambiavo proprio
prospettiva non so se vi ricordate
l'attimo fuggente robin williams un
certo punto fa una cosa bellissima monta
in piedi sulla cattedra e dice qualcosa
del tipo voi mi sa che vedete anche la
cessazione giusta dice che proprio gli
alunni perché vi starete chiedendo
perché lo faccio la leggo anch'io perché
sono stato sulla cattura per ricordare a
me stesso che devono vedere le cose da
un punto di vista diverso e io grazie
alla canzone squalo di quei perché non
stavo vedendo tutto da un punto di vista
diverso era un po come se fossi
realmente salito sulla cattedra e mi
rivedevo lì alla lavagna certa la carta
vedevo il baglio professore che spiegava
altre ma di ruffini tabelline poi guarda
famiglie alunni mi riguardava 18 porca
miseria
ci ha ragione quel bischero del dalai la
colpa non è mia la colpa non è sua la
colpa è mia e di noi insegnanti che alle
volte tendiamo a parlare un linguaggio
che è
assolutamente lontano rispetto al
linguaggio che parlano le studentesse e
gli studenti che abbiamo di fronte e
allora in maniera naturale simile a
formare un muro tra noi e loro e io mi
solito come si fa arrivare dall'altra
parte del muro ora non voglio avere la
presunzione proprio ad andare lì dare
una spallata e buttare giù il muro ma
almeno sai a pallonetto arrivare
dall'altra parte del muro questo vorrei
far così fa è la chiave era proprio
quella canzone squalo di quei perché ne
tornai a casa con mille idee in testa la
prima cosa che fece chiamare michele mio
fratello con cui scrivo tutto quello che
faccio gli dissi o lele ma secondo te
come
racconterebbe la regola del teorema di
ruffini e perché no
quello che è venuto fuori è stato un
processo creativo per noi abbastanza
interessante anche per quello che poi è
accaduto dopo ora
ci siamo messi ad ascoltare
o di playlist di rap per entrare dentro
a quel mondo hanno scoperto un po di
cose anche sui rapper che ci hanno
permesso di scrivere questo nostro primo
pezzo didattico abbiamo fatto tanto che
ci hanno sempre dei nomi molto è detto
molto evocativi noi l'abbiamo chiamato
semplicemente il prof però il prof
immaginatevi proprio un rapper di quelli
veri che vengono dal getty dalle
periferie che hanno una vita difficile
un passato complicato
ecco il prof e ironia della sorte
contemporaneamente anche a un docente di
matematica non rapper insegnante di
matematica ora direi per quelli forti
prima che cominci un pezzo devono
mandare quelle frasi ad effetto che
arrivano alla pancia dell'ascoltatore
che ti fanno venire i brividi non lungo
la schiena
però non ci veniva in mente niente comi
che cosa potrebbe dire un rapper che
anche professore di matematica che a un
certo punto ne abbiamo vista era lassù
scritta quella frase la prima frase che
fa cominciare
il rap del teorema di ruffini che fa
così se stai attento in classe 6 già a
metà dell'opera
e poi parte e bella fare prima ora
convinto sì polinomi da scomporre come
tizio sio forse degli automi che scorre
via veloce come sulla lamborghini niente
panico sboccia col teorema di ruffini
prendi un numero e mettilo al posto
della hit come un prisma e le somme
amico questo non è un quiz e la vita
bella il numero che c'è per davvero e
quello la somma alla fine torna 0 ora
poi i rapper quelli veri fateci caso
l'abbiamo scoperto ascoltando tutte
queste playlist non cantano mai cioè se
sei un rapper rp non cane fa quasi
brutto cantare però ormai sono talmente
mainstream sono talmente famosi che si
possono permettere
il duetto il featuring arriva lei
biondissima che canta il ritornello
o
meno in condizione necessaria ma dirvi
condizione sufficiente adesso fai una
tabella con il sacco sulle dita piccoli
numero a sinistra eco efficienti
non solo in caserma poi sempre un po il
pcl ai multipli che sotto quelle bombe
sulla gente
vivendo perplessi
[Musica]
facciamo un esempio uno per dirlo è
fatto
[Musica]
uno come te non c'è nessuno 4 a meno uno
per 170 bazar è quello giusto per
davvero tutti insieme
come volevasi dimostrare
[Musica]
fattorizzazione quello che trovi cure in
base frutto delle tue spese di energie
volati via come quei soldi a fine mese è
scomposto polinomio meglio dei
professionisti frate fatti un
bell'applauso se in rete gli algebris t
bell a te che c'è
quasi
staccando presto rep poi i rapper che
abbiamo scoperto
è che prima che finisca il pezzo loro
devono salutare tutto il proprio gruppo
di lavoro c'è sempre finisce la canzone
mi salutano tu ma tutte le volte noi
paghiamo la propria pare però che il
prof non è da meno e li saluta uno per
uno bello
della vita agorà
non si può tv3 per intero il
dipartimento di matematica
[Musica]
fondazione no grazie rovigo dalla zia
ora
ora troppo buono
[Applauso]
troppo buono ora che è che è successo
che è successo dopo è successo che
questa canzone ha avuto per noi
assolutamente in maniera inaspettata un
buon riscontro per i numeri che facevamo
noi un ottimo riscontro ha fatto in meno
di 24 ore un milione di visualizzazioni
in dopo dopo due giorni a roma non ci
credo ancora era linkata sulla home page
la sapienza e il teorema di ruffini non
ci credevano tutto faccio io ci avevo la
calcolatrice toro il pi greco tatuata
alla roma non mi ma soprattutto mi
scrivevano le ragazze ei ragazzi suina
scrivendo o grande vaglio preso sette e
mezza il compito su polinomi canzone
bella zio del lazio ma c'è ma questa
cosa qui funziona davvero allora siamo
fatti prendere la mano siamo andati a
testa con michele siamo diventati una
boy band i supplenti italiani per
spiegare le leggi di keplero maniera
romanticissima abbiamo spiegato
l'anatomia e la fisiologia del muscolo
cardiaco al ritmo reggaeton so pazzo una
canzone che ovviamente si chiama el
corazon
abbiamo accettato anche l'invito del
parlamento europeo nel provare a
raccontare l'unione europea con una
canzone didattica e devo dire abbiamo
avuto dei problemi a trovare il genere
musicale adatto non ci veniva in mente
niente e poi a un certo punto abbiamo
che ti aspetta unione europea unione
europea ue
è diventato la canzone neomelodica alla
gigi d'alessio nella pazienza e rendono
l'organizzazione internazionale politica
economica ha carattere e sopranazionali
una roba del genere è diventata una roba
così
ora qual è qualcuno di voi mi potrebbe
chiedere ho capito ma che ci vuoi
raccontare baglioni cioè che un
professore realmente dovrebbe entrare in
classe cantare il congiuntivo
no non penso che però ecco penso che
ogni professore dovrebbe trovare il
proprio modo di comunicare penso che la
didattica sia la massima espressione
della comunicazione tramonte sicuramente
la comunicazione più importante che c'è
nella nostra società ma dovremmo
veramente lasciare il tempo ad ogni
insegnante nel lavorare a questa cosa
qua è una cosa che mi dicono spesso è
certo baglioni
che passeggiano dai dall insegnante di
matematica a stare su un palcoscenico da
insegnare a fare l'attore a fare il
cantante che io dico sì ma come che
passaggio non mi vengono in mente due
lavori così vicini se ci pensate un
insegnante ogni giorno entra in classe
che il suo teatro se siede alla carta
del suo palcoscenico c'è anche una
scenografia straordinaria c'è una
lavagna tutti i suoi oggetti ma
soprattutto c'è un pubblico fedelissimo
che sono i suoi studenti molto difficile
molto difficile che ogni ogni giorno
deve cercare di di conquistare ecco
quindi dovremo provare proprio ad
applicare le regole della comunicazione
alla didattica concludo così ricordando
anzi raccontandovi una cosa che non
dimenticherò mai un mio professore
d'italiano eroina quarta liceo
scientifico liceo piero gobetti in
provincia di firenze a bagno a ripoli
una mattina alla prima ora entro
trasportando un pesante leggio di legno
facendo una confusione è stratosferica
tant'è che noi vedremo quella scena e ci
viene spontaneo di stare in silenzio ci
rispondano poter passarci a vedere
quella cosa surreale lui prese questo
leggio lo mise al centro della classe
senza dire una parola noi zitti stando
addirittura a spingere la luce clicca
diventato tutto buio aprì un pochino la
tenda veniva illuminato soltanto da un
raggio dai primi raggi del mattino senza
dire una parola ha preso una vecchia
edizione della della divina commedia
la mise sulle giro e cominciò lo giorno
se ne andava el aire bruno toglieva gli
animali che sono in terra dalle fatiche
loro ed io solo uno apparecchiava a
sostenerla guerra si del cammino e si
della pietà te che ritrarrà la mente che
non era una roba straordinaria una
lezione bellissima veramente tutti
avevamo rapiti da questo modo di a
raccontarci la divina commedia tant'è
che io tornai a casa e forse ancor prima
di mangiare mi venne spontaneo di
prendere dallo zainetto la mia versione
della divina commedia e di andarmi a
rileggere quello che aveva appena
sentito in classe lo volevo fare era
proprio una necessità e quei nuovi versi
quello che versi quelle prime tre
terzine che aprono il secondo canto
dell'inferno della divina commedia di
dante alighieri io non mi sono scordati
ma in più nella vita perché quando un
professore fa una didattica ganz applica
le regole della comunicazione in una
maniera interessante alla didattica c'è
veramente il caso che uno si trasformi
roberto baggio pallonetto e si arriva
dall'altra parte del muro grazie mille
[Applauso]